[Musique]
alors bonjour à toutes et à tous bonne
rentrée surtout bonne lecture
et comme l'a dit christian jacq dans le
moine et le vénérable la passion de la
lecture est un refuge peut-être pour
échapper à un monde en folie mais
surtout la découverte des lois
éternelles sans lesquels l'homme devient
à moins qu'un animal alors tentons de
devenir encore plus humain avec la
lecture
alors nous sommes un groupe de
passionnés qui donc allons essayer de
vous faire partager la passion de livres
que nous avons beaucoup aimé nous allons
commencer que monique au de miniac qui
est conteuse qui travailla marmite et
fun comble du môle et qui va nous parler
de home de la célèbre toni morrison qui
viennent mais c'est bien elle vient de
merci bernard nous laisser parler toni
morrison est donc née en 1931 dans
l'ohio elle est famille ouvrière de
quatre enfants elle est décédé cet été
c'est une forte personnalité et un titre
de journal qui disait d'elle la
piraterie laisse des lettres américaines
sennour américaine auquel a écrit
plusieurs livres le plus bleu belhow et
caetera et caetera et moi j'ai choisi
hommes et c'est c'est son année dit je
crois alors en fait c'est il ya le héros
s'appelle franck monnet donc tout le
monde plaisantait toujours sur son nom
parce qu'il n'avait jamais à sous et ce
récit pour moi il ya deux aspects bien
côté sombre et à côté lumineux
donc il ya la guerre de corée en toile
de fond avec il est parti de son village
de sa petite ville avec deux de ses
meilleurs amis ses amis d'enfance ils
ont fait la guerre et il a perdu ses
amis dans des conditions abominables
site c'est tous ces passages de la
guerre sont violence une violence à
affreuse et sur n'est pas remis et puis
il ya la mort la présence de la mort
d'une petite fille est qui et qui le
harcèle et on comprend enfin la fin du
livre pourquoi je vous dirai rien à vous
de le lire et puis à la la
il a été très choqué aussi voilà parce
qu'il assistait à un fils est venu et
les compagnons du compagne m'en fous
parce qu'on a exigé de lui de tuer son
père c'était lui ou son père et parce
qu'en fait ils feront n'a fait des paris
sur exactement comme comme comme les
combats de coqs
c'était en fait il fallait qu'ils
combattent et ils pouvaient pas sortir
de cette ornière et on lui a dit tu ton
père ou c'est toi qui les hauts faits
damman et l'a tué son père et savait sa
vie et fait chuter et ça a marqué
beaucoup franck monnet qui plus tard
après je vous dirais qu a rendu hommage
au père je vous dirai donc et traverse
pour aller chercher sa soeur avec qui il
a des souvenirs d'enfance c'est entre
autres les chevaux il ya tout un passage
sur les chevaux et s'est toujours occupé
sa petite soeur parce qu'ils soient vus
avait une famille archi compliquée par
une grand-mère abominable les parents et
de l'existant donc il s'est toujours
senti responsable de sa soeur et il
apprend que sa soeur après un parcours
difficile avec un homme qui sait qui et
c'est en fait moquer d'elle se trouvait
chez travailler chez un docteur un
docteur complètement fou qui faisait des
expériences généraux logique affreuse
sur sur les femmes entre autres sur sa
soeur donc elle est complètement son
corps est meurtri enfin bon allez allez
y compris comme si elle était anéantie
quado qu il traverse tout le pays et
c'est l'époque de la ségrégation le nord
le sud pour aller chercher sa petite
soeur et là ça devient plus lumineux
donc il est là il la retrouve le tout
son amour qui qu'il a pour sa soeur et
lui donne il l'aide
et puis il ya des passages qui revient
il pose des questions sur ces fameux
chevaux de son enfance il découvre le
pourquoi pour la petite fille et c'est
douloureux et tout mais après il est
apaisée et puis il veut il veut redonner
sa dignité ou kido redevient un homme
debout à ce père qui a été tué par la
force des choses et en fait on sent
qu'il veut qu'il veut après tout la
violence de la guerre
la violence de sa vie il n'a pas pu
construire quelque chose d'important
dans sa vie parce que il y avait
toujours il avait eu une histoire
d'amour mais il y avait toujours la
guerre en toile de fond sa compagne le
comprenais pas très bien mais là on sent
un peu plus apaisement et peut-être
qu'il va y va aller vers quelque chose
de plus plus apaisant voilà donc
s'étonner au morrison hommes et c'est
dans la collection 10 18
un auteur vraiment importante aux
nombreux soutiens
merci monica comme audi couronne
maintenant clair nous parler de marie
fernante qui vaut du pays mais me fais
un malheur
[Musique]
alors ma me fernande du pays ma me
fernande c'était la voisine de adeline
rivière qui est l'auteur de ce roman
lorsqu'elle habitait dans les landes
mamie fernande n'a jamais quitté son
village sauf quand elle est devenue
l'héroïne de ce roman m'a me fernande et
veuve elle a deux enfants qui ne vivent
pas dans son village et sa vie c'est son
chien son potager sa maison ses poules
son cochon et l'amitié de ses voisins
et notamment l'amitié d'une adolescente
qui via peut-être chez elle clémence
clémence qui aiment se réfugier chez sa
grand mère parce que clémence elle vit
des choses qui sont un peu difficiles
dans sa famille son papa vient de perdre
son travail donc beaucoup de tension le
climat familial est dure et elle aime se
retrouver chez cette grand mère qui est
simple qui est un modèle de l'écologie
elle vit de presque rien elle est né
écologiste parfaite et elle mourra
écologistes parfaite cette femme là
cependant il arrive il ya un événement
particulier qui fait que mamie fernande
quitte brutalement sa maison son village
personne ne sait pourquoi
et tout le monde est très inquiet
notamment clémence qui va mener les
enquêtes elle pense que ma me fernande
c'était kidnappé et donc elle mène une
petite enquête pour essayer de retrouver
mam fermant bien sûr ah bon c'est un peu
compliqué et mamie fernante va parcourir
la france pendant trois semaines elle va
découvrir notre monde moderne autre
monde de la consommation d'affaires faux
lent pour elle elle fait de belles
rencontres elle rencontre des hommes et
des femmes qui vont lui permettre de
retrouver son chemin en retrouver sa
maison et son retour est accueillie
vraiment comme un miracle donc ses
enfants les enfants d'amis fernande
viennent pour son retour
clémence est là les parents de clément
sont là le frère de clémence est en fête
et les amis aussi qu'elle a rencontré
pendant ce voyage est en fait ce moment
de retrouvailles fait que
les liens vont vous ce qui était un peu
abîmée bas se refont et est en fait
c'est vraiment un retour miraculeux
voilà ce livre je les lui il ya
plusieurs années déjà avec ma fille
ophélie qui avait 8 ans et en fait tous
les soirs on lisait une étape et ce fut
vraiment un très joli voyage
merci clair pour ce voyage si nathalie
de nathalie vol qui est maître de
conférences à l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines tout à côté va nous
emmener en suède avec le cavalier
suédois de léo perutz tout à fait merci
beaucoup bernard je venais en effet vous
parler de ce livre qui est un classique
mais un classique qui a été très
longtemps oublié et je me suis rendu
compte que finalement peu de gens l'avez
lu c'est pour ça que j'avais envie de
vous en parler aujourd'hui
alors léo perutz il est né à prague
c'est un contemporain de kafka
ils sont d'ailleurs travailler dans une
compagnie d'assurance et bourgueil
s'appelait léo perutz kafka aventure
donc c'était un admirateur de grands
admirateurs de de beyrouth et il a été
très populaire cette hauteur dans les
années 20 30 et ensuite après que les
nazis ont interdit ces livres en
allemagne il avait complètement tombé
dans l'oubli et on l'a
on retrouve en france quand il est
traduit dans les années 80 c'est vrai
que le livre revient alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ce cavalier suédois c'est un
compte et c'est un pont qui débute par
un prologue très énigmatique on a une
petite fille qui chaque nuit est visité
par le spectre de son père qui est un
noble parti faire la guerre et ensuite
le livre commence et le livre débute on
est en 1701
on est dans la forêt fait froid et deux
hommes qui chacun qui fidler chacun suit
son côté deux hommes se rencontrent dans
une forêt et ce qui va se passer c'est
que tout va les opposer on en a un qui
est un voleur en vagabond et l'autre
c'est un déserteur déserteurs des armées
de pologne et qui veut rejoindre les
forces armées donc du roi de suède
puisque tu évoquais la suède
et alors ils vont ils vont partager la
faim le froid la neige et ils vont se
retrouver dans un moulin en t et c'est
là qu'ils vont sceller un pacte d'amitié
mais que vaut l'amitié quand il ya la
guerre et surtout quand il ya l'amour
l'amour qui va conduire l'un des deux a
usurpé l'identité de l'autre bon je vais
pas vous en dire plus parce que qu'il
faut vraiment le lire mais
ce qui est vraiment extraordinaire dans
ce conte qui est un conte fantastique
c'est que vraiment on va remuer des
questions très profonde qu'est ce que
l'identité qu'est ce que la jalousie
l'amour on va parler des compromissions
auquel dont les hommes sont capables on
va parler de l'arrêt donc si on enfin
vraiment des thèmes universels et c'est
vraiment une réflexion sur le sens de la
destinée mais c'est écrit alors su
évoquer hitchcock d'une émission passe
est vraiment dans un rythme haletant
avec du suspens comme dans comme dans un
film avec je vote donc vraiment un
livret a va découvrir ou à redécouvrir
nous laisse comme ça ça ouais y'a plus
qu'à aller chercher
merci de l'anatolie pour ce voyage en
suisse si vous voulez pour terminer le
jeu propose un voyage en saône et loire
veuillez pardonner de parler devant mon
dernières publications sa recueil de
nouvelles sur la vie du terroir de
saône-et-loire ces fameux territoire
oublié qu'ils sont à une heure de
l'autoroute où il ya moins de monde il
ya plein de maisons à vendre s'il ya
beaucoup de souffrance et donc mais j'ai
voulu témoigner que ça se passait mieux
dans un et 60 70 forum une anecdote
quand j'étais môme on avait 9 10 ans il
ya deux tanks ont traversé la cour de
l'école des garçons ce qu'ils avaient le
champ 3 à côté c'est une année de plus a
tous marqués quand vous avez ça à 10 ans
il ya des camarades qui a été blessé
tout ça et donc j'ai voulu raconter tout
ça pis ma venue d'autres histoires
lorsqu'un terrain ce qui est étonnant
c'est que quand vous avez commencé
l'écriture de ce recueil de nouvelles
je suis tombé sur le livre de pierre
michon permission qui s'appelle vies
minuscules
c'était dans les années 80-90 lui parle
de la creuse il fait vivre des
personnages 5 de la creuse mais comme on
disait tout à l'heure le miracle de la
littérature c'est d'arriver à redonner
liés ils vont arrêter immortaliser des
gens simples parce que voilà il n'y a
pas de vie simple tout le monde se bat
dans la vie et donc j'ai voulu parler
aussi de gens simples qui ont marqué et
intérieure pendant le portrait d'un
médecin de campagne qui roule avec ses
deux shows dans toute la campagne
jour et nuit qui prenaient pas de
vacances le genre de personnage qui
n'existe plus maintenant avec que tout
le monde regrette des jeunes de mai 68
il faut un peu des bêtises mais pas trop
méchant l'aider descente de rivière en
kayak faire revivre tout un beau terroir
qui malheureusement est un peu en
désespérance actuellement et ce livre
sera bien sûr au salon des écrivains
d'elancourt le dimanche 24 heures et il
est préfacé par patrice franceschi donc
et président d'honneur du salon
d'elancourt qui au nom de l'amitié m'a
fait l'honneur de cette préface très
très sympathique parce que la boïna vie
que ce sont trois ans autour du monde
mais la descente de rivière en kayak à
toulon-sur-arroux jusqu'à autant
intéressant aussi une belle région
il faut redécouvrir ces terroirs de
province qui souffrent vraiment il faut
aller les voir ils sont très gentils on
mange blain est un bon acteur pour faire
du vélo du kayak de la pêche et les
hollandais le savent bien parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de copies volant dé là bas
merci et bonne rentrée encore merci
merci bernard
[Musique]